what is happening there reject nation
greg
and john here we're going to watch from
our friend warren over at the cosmic
wonders spider-man 4
tonight venom setup easter eggs and
clues i was waiting for this video to be
released last night i was on the phone
with warren and he did mention to me
what the
topic of the video he was going to be
doing is i started throwing in like
here's why i think
there is a possibility with the rumors
that they might be trying to get a
spider-man 4
looking at the morbius trailer and the
venom trailer how i think
they might actually be hinting at a
multiverse that leads into a spider-man
4 with toby
i have this whole thing i want to see if
any of that's mentioned i'm going to
call plagiarism even though he probably
already had the idea too beforehand he
didn't reveal any details to me throw
that out there
that i have some thoughts too so let's
see what's in store baby
[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yesterday we got the first
official teaser trailer for venom let
there be carnage and it did not
disappoint copyright claims
carnage like i said yesterday
but luckily they did i personally liked
the trailer and if you liked it or you
didn't like it let me know why in the
comments down below
now there was a lot that happened in
this trailer yesterday but there are a
few main points that are going to have
some significant
impacts on the future of the sp umc the
sony pictures
i forgot that was an acronym
spider-man section not the entire mcu
but just the mcu that spider-man exists
in which i'll explain in a bit but today
i really want to talk about these main
points and talk about the possibility
of a setup for spider-man 4
involving toby mcguire this has been a
report
for some time now and i want to dive
into it and talk about how venom let
there be carnage could set this up
venom 2 combined with everything that
we're going to see in the spider verse
that's coming up in spider-man no way
home
could very much set us up for a
spider-man 4. and we're already starting
to kind of see some of the evidence for
this
in the teaser trailer in the trailer for
morbius and of course from all of the
reports from spider-man no way home
so let's break it down but quick
reminder about my stormbreaker giveaway
to enter all you have to do is subscribe
to my channel and cosmic culture
details in the description down below
now the first thing to acknowledge
about the venom 2 trailer is the stan
lee
cameo and mrs chan store if you missed
it when venom says hi
to mrs chan when he brings out his
tentacle he slaps a magazine and it's
stan lee
gotta recognize stan the man but here's
the conspiracy theory that everybody is
talking about
in this trailer we see the daily bugle
and one scene eddie brock is going over
a bunch of different papers and
we see the daily bugle on his computer
in the background
and then when we see stephen graham's
character which has been revealed to be
detective
mulligan we see that he is reading the
daily bugle and here's where things
start to get really really interesting
this daily bugle is seemingly the exact
same daily bugle from the sam raimi
spiderman
exactly if you compare the two logos
they are exactly
the same like really exactly the same
as you can see here so of course people
are starting to talk about how this
could actually be the sam raimi universe
specifically the sony picture universe
of marvel characters
could still be that same universe where
toby maguire
exists and i love where everybody's
head's at i would
absolutely love for this to be the case
but
it's not at least it really doesn't seem
like it could be because
like my buddy chris said over at cosmic
culture we already had a
venom and an eddie brock specifically
in the sam raimi universe in spider-man
3. so
this venom and eddie brock can't really
be in the samurai universe because there
already was a venom and eddie brock
now don't let that multiverse though
with toby mcguire because there is still
a possibility that it could happen
and there is a little bit of evidence
suggesting that
it might but what if no humor me here
what if spider-man no way home they
actually the post-credits scene is
toby mcguire he's supposed to go back to
his universe and he lands in like the
world where venomous
and more bsr and all of them you know
yeah that would be such an interesting i
don't think it would happen it doesn't
feel
likely but i just think that'd be a
really cool post credit scene like oh
damn he's going to be going up against
it yeah
that'd be neat let's first start off by
talking about the reports
of spider-man 4 and toby mcguire
actually staying
kind of in the mcu for a little bit i
think most people know by now that
spider-man no way home the next
spider-man film with tom holland is
very heavily reported to be a
spider-verse multiverse film with
no doubt spider-man showing up and
andrew garfield spider-man showing up
doctor strange is going to be one of the
main characters of the movie and
spider-man no way home is going to lead
directly
into doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness so clearly the multiverse is
going to be kind of a prominent part of
no way home but of course the biggest
news is the return of tobey maguire and
andrew garfield as their respective
spider-man
and according to geekocitymag.com they
said that they've heard talks about
tobey maguire spider-man
actually continuing on into doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
now as far as the story goes of why they
would do this there are ways that make
sense if toby maguire spider-man finds
himself in the main mcu timeline with
tom holland spider-man he may not be
able to get back
that's where doctor strange could come
into play and that's where we could see
him appear in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness because he would
need doctor strange to get back to his
universe
then we have another report actually
several reports talking about how there
could be a spider-man 4
and this could be starring toby maguire
spider-man
a lot of outlets have been reporting
this but i believe it was giant freaking
robot who were the first to do so
and this would be incredibly insane and
awesome if this happened and my buddy
greg at the real rejects was talking
about how
venom let there be carnage could
actually set up spider-man
but then he thought about the fact that
venom let there be carnage can't be in
the same
raimi universe because of eddie brock
however i don't think
that really matters because right now we
are in a time
of the multiverse sony spider-man
universe
is most likely going to be affected by
the multiverse in spider-man no way home
now we don't really know the full
details of so weird
it's like he's a great friend of mine i
do i talk with him like every week on
the phone
in the video like oh you mentioned
i mean yeah like with the multiverse it
creates all kinds of conundrums but the
thing that was popping into my noggin
was how
and i don't know if he's gonna go into
it andy circus said that
they're not aware of spider-man these
characters like eddie brock in this
world
he specifically stated that it couldn't
be within the raimi versus these films
but i was like okay but what about the
multiverse
so if tom holland is dealing with like
the villains
of the andrew garfield world and the
toby maguire one like green goblin doc
ock
electro what if there was like some
weird conundrum that happened where
spider-man toby maguire as you see in
the morbius trailer that's the
spider-man
toby maguire one if he is now dealing
with the ones that should be with tom
holland you know like kind of
mish-mashing them around a little bit
yeah there's a cool way to do it the
deal between sony and disney slash
marvel
but from what we've heard they made a
deal to where spider-man could appear in
the sp umc and some of the spumc
characters could appear in the mcu as
long as it's in
a spider-man film and a spider-man film
only
so venom in theory could appear in a
spider-man film but he couldn't appear
in an iron man film a captain america
film captain marvel
only spider-man and there is proof like
i mentioned that toby maguire spider-man
could
be getting set up right now in the sp
umc
many of you know and have probably heard
me talk about spider-man being
in the morbius trailer well kind of he's
on the wall
and over him the word murderer now of
course we're thinking that this could be
tom holland spider-man because
of the fact that it has the word
murderer over him and people think he
murdered mysterio
however the spider-man that we actually
see here is the sam
raimi spider-man aka tobey maguire so he
could
actually already exist in this universe
and how is that possible
well the same way that he could actually
appear in the mcu
the multiverse you have to keep in mind
that sony really really wants to be a
part of the mcu
and they really want to use it please
let me know in their films in the sp umc
and they're already using characters
that were in spider-man in their own
universe
vulture was seen in the morbius trailer
as well and of course he's in the mcu
so we're already seeing the crossover
here and part of that crossover could be
toby maguire spider-man in this universe
now we don't really have any details
about what spider-man 4 could be or
which universe it could take place in
because sony does have the rights to
toby maguire spider-man
disney and sony have only talked about
and made deals about rights for tom
holland spider-man now of course we
don't know the ins and outs of any deal
that they may have going on right now
but it would be kind of cool to have
another tom holland spider-man movie and
then at the same time another toby
maguire spider-man movie and this maybe
could kind of be the bridge between the
two universes because toby maguire
spider-man is going to be in no way home
and it seems like he exists somewhat in
the sp umc
so maybe in no way home as the universes
kind of start to fall apart and kind of
start to collide with each other
which is why the other spider-man will
be in the film maybe they'll start to
explain what all is happening maybe toby
maguire's spider-man does decide to go
back but he ends up in the wrong
universe he ends up in the universe
where we have tom hardy's eddie brock
then maybe we could get a decent venom
versus
between tom hardy and toby mcguire who
knows what could happen
it would be like course correcting the
thing that happened with spider-man 3
because
i constantly forget about
topher grace when i think about
spider-man 3 for some reason i think of
everything but that
is because the studio crammed him into
this yeah
so i forget about that so if you found a
way to like redo it course correct it oh
that would be pretty neat even though
sam raimi has no interest in benefits
nah dude morby is two
then we finally get tobey maguire going
up against morbius like one of the
original spiderman four ideas
there's something that you could do here
some cool fan theories to go out here
the
possibilities are really really
limitless for this and i actually do
hope this will happen
if the reports about spider-man 4 are
true and if this really is toby maguire
spider-man
in the morbius trailer we could be
getting tobey maguire spider-man in the
sp umc
and the merger of universes could
explain why the daily bugle is exactly
the same
after all we've seen jjj end spider-man
far from home in the post-credits scene
however his daily bugle seems to be a
little bit different so it's clearly
from a different universe
so the fact that the daily bugle logo in
venom let there be carnage is the exact
same logo
as the spider-man sam raimi tobey
maguire trilogy
is good evidence that it could be the
same universe not the original
universe of tobey maguire but perhaps a
merged
universe there truthfully is so much
that could happen so let me know what
you think about this
in the comments down below do you like
this idea of venom let there be carnage
possibly setting up toby maguire
spider-man 4
if so how would you do it let me know
down below and don't forget to subscribe
so you can stay up to date on all of the
latest spider-man and venom news don't
forget to like the video and for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof if toby maguire
is going to be in doctor strange
multiverse and madness that's really
cool
i mean if it's at the end of no way home
i could see it just being a post-credit
scene of toby mcguire dropping right
into doctor strange or something like
that
it's just the biggest puzzle piece to
all of this the biggest puzzle piece
more than that daily bugle logo more
than j jonah jameson is the morbius
photo the fact that is
toby maguire spiderman it's a very
specific
thing to throw yeah now the question is
why does it say
murderer venom doesn't look like it's
dealing with multiverse morbius doesn't
look like it's dealing with
multiverse there's nothing there that
seems to indicate multiverse
that's what i keep wondering about now
is maybe they're gonna surprise us with
more
maybe the spider-man movie itself is
part of the ruse it's like yes focus all
your attention on this one movie so that
we can surprise you with a bunch of
multiversal stuff across
several movies maybe but then there's
also like andy
andy it's andy circus's comments that
really have thrown me off
yeah of him saying they're not aware of
spider-man i don't know if he's just
doing that to
intentionally throw you off but it's
throwing me off yeah a little bit
yeah undoubtedly it's throwing me off
guys what do you think about this theory
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
hit that like button click that
notification bell subscribe to cosmo
wonder if you haven't done so already
catch you guys soon